gut sehr gut jetzt geht keiner dran aber
es funktioniert also ich bin wirklich
extrem positiv überrascht davon man kann
bluetooth machen man kann sogar alter
man kann sogar trotz des benutzten etwas
glaubt willkommen bei einem neuen video
irgendwie ist mir vor der wahl heute r
gestern war draußen irgendwie so 5 grad
und heute sind es 13 leute also nochmal
ich hoffe euch geht es allen gut viele
von euch haben wahrscheinlich mein
letztes video gesehen ist wieder
ziemlich abgegangen hat mich natürlich
sehr gefreut wir waren zum zweiten mal
in den trends leider nur mit solchen
videos haben wir gut ist dann halt soja
und das erste davon das liegt ja schon
einige zeit zurück also um genau zu sein
ungefähr eineinhalb wochen oder zwei
wochen und in dem video habe ich jetzt
auch schon sachen bestellt wie zum
beispiel eine rolex oder eines smart
watch ich hatte letztens zum video schon
gezeigt dass die meisten dieser produkte
erst mitte oder anfang april ankommen
werden
ich habe allerdings warum auch immer
jetzt schon zwei produkte erhalten und
zwar einmal die smart watch und einmal
die rolex und ich habe mir gedacht bevor
ich jetzt wirklich so 100 wartet bis
sich dann halt fünf oder sechs produkte
habt kann ich doch eigentlich schon mal
diese beiden sachen zeigen ich meine
sind ja coole sachen wo ich auf jeden
fall gespannt bin was drin ist also ich
hätte die jetzt zum beispiel die smart
wird auf jeden fall zu den
interessantesten produkt gezählt was ich
halt bestellt habe und die können wir
dann auch wirklich mal ausprobieren
alter ist das jetzt dunkel hier so bevor
wir uns allerdings anfang ich kann mal
kurz die produkte holen wollte ich
einmal nachschauen was denn da so
wirklich auf der website steht was das
so sein soll beziehungsweise was die
sachen können sollten und wie teuer sie
waren weil das weiß ich gar nicht mehr
so genau
also moment so also hier sind die beiden
sachen wir haben hier einmal die uhr die
ich schon zumindest die verpackung habe
ich schon aufgemacht einfach weil ich so
überrascht war dass das schon da ist
weil im internet stand eigentlich dass
das erst viel später ankommt und ich war
mir halt unsicher ob es jetzt wirklich
dieses produkt ist was ich halt gedacht
habe dass mich rein geschaut und das
hier kann man irgendwie zwei drei tage
später
und das müsste so weit ich jetzt aus dem
internet entnehmen kann die smart sein
smart watch list nicht zum waschen ist
eine smart watch so läuft und ich wollte
jetzt erstmal noch mal kurz schauen mit
euch zusammen was das denn oder was ich
von diesem produkt zu versprechen da ist
falls man das so sagt also wenn ihr
wisst was ich meine halt vielleicht
einfach
gucken was hier so stetig zu den sachen
also hier kann man sehen kommen bis zum
siebten dritten an
wir haben jetzt heute den fünften
dritter und das kam wie schon am ersten
dritten also das fand ich das hier steht
jetzt komischerweise dass es noch nicht
da ist bzw halt nur fast da es ist aber
schon da also da bin ich mir hundert
prozent sicher dass es auch wirklich das
ist so und hier das gleiche haben wir
die touchscreen smart watch mit kamera
tfk bluetooth smart watch für android
gut dass meine mama ein android handy
hat sich kommt auch bis zum siebten
dritten an ist aber schon da so und das
habe ich anscheinend für 18 euro gekauft
wenn man hier jetzt mal schaut man kann
es auf deutsch auf jeden fall nutzen
hierbei der sprache schlaf trecker
message reminder call reminder also ich
bin jetzt wirklich hier von 188 euro
runtergesetzt also ob das wirklich
funktioniert da bin ich gespannt und
dann gehe ich vielleicht noch mal hier
kurz auf die uhr die habe ich für 17
augen gekauft luxus herrenuhr also es
ist glaube ich keinen also es ist glaube
ich kein rolex duplikat einfach ich habe
rolex eingegeben und ich bin eben wie
die ganze zeit davon aus sagen das ist
halt so ein rolex fei aber ist es glaube
ich gar nicht genau beschreibung
produkttyp blabla keine ahnung kann ich
nicht viel mit anfang ist jetzt nicht
gerade eine sprache die ich hier
verstehen kann
gut also dass sind die beiden sachen
insgesamt für 17 augen gekauft und für
18 euro versand konnte man dann ungefähr
auch nochmal acht euro pro produkt
darauf rechnen das heißt ich habe
insgesamt für beide sachen ungefähr 50
euro bezahlt ja und wie gesagt die
ganzen anderen sachen das dauert halt
noch eine ewigkeit ich weiß auch nicht
warum genau diese beiden sachen jetzt
schon da sind keine ahnung nicht
wahrscheinlich am versandhändler und hat
vier grad zum beispiel bei der uhr
gesehen hier bin ich vielleicht kurz
noch mal ein foto ein dass sie gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus
ich würde sagen wir schauen jetzt mal
rein also das ist die verpackung steht
drauf dax yahoo mail time interesting
man sieht auf jeden fall schon das ist
eher so ein billig druck ist also
wirklich hochwertig fühlt sich das jetzt
nicht in der hand an will macht es
einfach mal austeilen oder wie hier ist
das doch vor sein ist es vielleicht eine
kleine beschreibung hier sind einfach
schon rechtschreibfehler drin
auf englisch heißt das wirkt sehr
unseriös aber hat halt auch nur 17 euro
und hier haben wir noch irgendeinen
anderen scheinen wir ja hier for you to
offer aber based solutions for your
choice dialog in forward to your city
kann also danke für den kauf bisschen
übersetzt und das ist halt dann auch
schon die uhr
die ich gestellt habt ich bin vielleicht
auch kurz normale nahaufnahme ich würde
sagen wir machen das ganze jetzt mal auf
und haben dann hier die uhr entweder ich
bin jetzt gerade blöd oder hat doch
jetzt läuft sie somit haben wir dann
gerade so durch nach zehn jahren habe
ich dir jetzt auch mal fertig ausgepackt
ich war noch so folie darum also ich bin
jetzt wirklich keine uhren kenner aber
ich muss sagen so wirklich ich hatte
natürlich auch schon mal so übel ist die
billig ohne in der hand und so krass
billig fühlt sich das gar nicht mal an
also ich bin wirklich erstmal so positiv
überrascht was ich allerdings sagen muss
ich glaube hier ist was kaputt weil ich
kann wirklich irgendwo irgendwas
verstellen hier dran
das geht einfach nicht die uhr läuft
zwar aber man kann nicht zu erstellen
also ihr könnt ihr eure meinung zu der
uhr in die kommentare schreiben ich
hätte wirklich was deutlich schlechteres
erwartet für 17 euro eigentlich krass
ich guck ich meine ruhe habe ich noch
zum laufen kriege ich habe gerade schon
probiert aber irgendwie wird das nichts
deswegen würde ich sagen wir gehen jetzt
erst mal zu der smart watch über aber
ich finde werde ich jetzt tragen würde
ich glaube da würden viele denken das
ist eine teure uhr ja absolut 17 euro
pro leute und hier ist jetzt hoffentlich
die smart watch sinne
jawohl wir haben hier die smart watch
kann man ja schon sehen verified by
witch steht ja sogar drauf ist wirklich
von mich okay die ist hey ich hab
eigentlich nicht an ich habe eine
goldene bestellt oder was habe ich
bestellte ich habe eigentlich eine
schwarze bestellt also auf dem bild
sieht es schon mal anders aus wir haben
hier drin einmal ein auf ladekabel
nämlich neun beziehungsweise ganz
normales bricht weg habe für android
halt und beschreibungen the power of
which of the witch jetzt bin ich
wirklich krass gespannt ob das ding
funktioniert so gezielt aus wie man hier
sehen kann erst ist das ist nicht orange
es ist so
pink schimmert auch mal hier vielleicht
kurz nach aufnahme also so sieht die uhr
aus ich bin wirklich wieder positiv
überrascht es sieht echt nach
vernünftiger qualität aus als wäre es
halt wirklich seiner smart watch die man
mal eben für 115 euro im laden kaufen
kann
mit kameras sogar mal gespannt ob die
dort angeht
wahrscheinlich muss man die erste
auflage ich schließe sie einfach mal
kurz an meinem macbook und dann gucken
wir mal ob die angeblich man das usb
kabel rein leute gerade alter gerade ist
die mobile aufnahme abgebrochen aber die
us einfach angegangen alter sie
funktioniert sogar leute schaut mal hier
man kann hier runter scrollen man kann
nachrichten senden und man kann die
wirklich mit touch benutzen
man kann sogar anrufen das hätte ich
jetzt wirklich nicht gedacht man kann
bluetooth machen
man kann sogar alltag man kann sogar
wozzeck benutzen dort schon mal kurz das
handy von meiner mutter das ist ein
samsung vier mini oder so und ich
versuche das mal zu verbinden da bin ich
echt mal gespannt so leute kurzes update
wir haben es gerade hinbekommen die uhr
funktioniert jetzt also sie steht jetzt
auf 20 vor 320 nach 3 und das geht
wirklich also hier
ich bin überrascht hätte ich nicht
gedacht dass man so ein teil kriegt ja
und jetzt muss man auf smartphones zu
laufen kriegen dann ist sie ja schon mal
kurz das handy und ich versuche jetzt
einfach mal über bluetooth mit dem handy
zu verbinden wenn es geklappt hat melde
ich mich wieder so leute also es hat
geklappt
ich habe dieses ding hier j 5 dm genannt
und konnte mich damit koppeln
also schon mal krass whatsapp kann ich
allerdings nicht verwenden
das geht nicht weil das irgend eine
veraltete version ich werde echt total
verwundert wenn das funktionieren würde
hier gibt es noch facebook vielleicht
probieren wir das mal aus ich kann jetzt
wirklich über die uhr anrufen und ich
kann zum beispiel jetzt sachen sehen wie
mit wem als letztes telefoniert wurde
hier zb mein bruder merlin
oder hier alex das bin ja ich und ich
würde sagen ich ruf einfach nur kurz
mein bruder über die uhr an also ich bin
wirklich extrem positiv überrascht davon
gut sehr gut jetzt geht keiner dran aber
es funktioniert auch so sachen wie die
facebook app oder twitter sind schon
automatisch darauf installiert man kann
den rechner benutzten man kann auf dem
ding einfach rechnen
man kann einen kalender eintragen und so
weiter
der touchscreen ist jetzt nicht wirklich
so ausgebaut aber er funktioniert also
ich muss an dieser stelle sagen ich bin
wirklich total überrascht damit habe ich
null gerechnet dass beides optimal
funktioniert vor allem von der smart
watch bin ich richtig begeistert für 18
euro
eine komplette smart watch ist zwar noch
aber sie funktioniert da muss man
einfach mal bedenken wie weit und wie
gut die technik schon ist dass es
möglich ist für 18 euro
whatsapp nutzen zu können facebook
twitter anrufe tätigen zu können
kalendereinträge machen zu können
taschenrechner hat man drauf für 18 euro
alles in diesem kleinen dingen hier drin
das finde ich wirklich krass und ja also
ich kann es nur empfehlen weil jene
smartbooks brauch oder halt überlegt
euch eine anzuschaffen bevor ihr euch
jetzt irgendeinen dingen führt 300 euro
kaufte so gibt es ja auch kauft euch
doch erstmal bei erscheine und guckt ob
ihr mit dem dingen wirklich zufrieden
sein oder auch deshalb sinn macht so
anständig am abend zu tragen kann
natürlich auch sein dass das ding bald
schon schrott ist aber es funktioniert
sollte noch ein ganz kleiner nachtrag
ich bin grad am schneiden guck mal wenn
man die an macht ich habe ja ganz die
kamera vergessen man kann einfach hier
drauf gehen und hat dann hier die kamera
sie ist zwar sehr schlecht aber bekam
war da drin
guck mal hier sieht man mich so leicht
ich weiß ich habe das sehen kann worte
ja es halt schwer also die ist grausam
aber es funktioniert also man kann fotos
machen kannst ja das waren jetzt zwei
billigprodukte einfach mal live getestet
ich würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat was es dann nach oben da wenn ich
auf eines der handys testen sollte wenn
es halt ankommt die ich letztens
bestellt haben lassen nach oben da
sicher dann und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder morgen gibt es ein cooles video
leute ich wünsche einen schönen tag
getrennt